c'est une nouvelle menace qui plane sur
les producteurs de bananes une menace
bien plus grande que la serre kospi rose
ou le charançon le fusarium beauxis pour
rome c'est un champignon déjà connu des
planteurs il avait mis à terre la
production mondiale de bananes dans les
années 50
aujourd'hui il fait des ravages en
colombie et vu la mondialisation des
échanges commerciaux
le risque de contamination est bien
présent quand on sait qu'il ya beaucoup
de produits comme la tomate comme les
citrons comme les fleurs qui sort de ce
pays là je me pose la question si elle
n'est pas encore ici qu'il y ait des
contrôles assez drastiques
parce que j'ai vu des photos des diapos
je peux vous dire que ça donne une image
apocalyptique c'est à dire que le
bananier s'éclate les feuilles tombent
ses pieds ou comme si on avait piqué un
champs de bananes au glyphosate les
images apocalyptiques dont pas cet
agriculteur les voici des plantations à
l'agonie et l'assurance de ne plus
pouvoir produire de banane sur ses sols
carrelés sport du fusarium sont très
résistantes elles pourraient survivre
plus de 30 ans dans le sol est contaminé
les terres avoisinantes au gré des
ruissellements et des déplacements de
marchandises ou de personnes
aucun traitement de l'éradiquer un
scénario catastrophe pour le vice
président de la chambre d'agriculture
c'est la fin d'une production pour la
maintenir pendant de temps pendant au
moins dix ans donc c'est pas client on
et j'avoue qu'on est très très inquiet
et on suit ça de très près parce que
c'est ce sera un changement crête
complet de mode de production des
productions dans quoi on n'est pas
encore prêt à ça depuis la propagation
de ce que l'on nomme aussi la maladie du
panama les autorités françaises sont en
alerte
l' agence régionale de sécurité
sanitaires préconisent dans ce rapport
la désinfection des matériels pouvant
avoir été en contact avec le sol ainsi
que les containers de marchandises en
provenance de zones infestées un casse
tête qui implique la mobilisation de
toutes les autorités compétentes et des
acteurs économiques on refoule les
partenaires souillé par mater et ça
provoque des gros problèmes parce qu'il
faut des potées la marchandise renvoyer
le contraire voilà c'est vraiment
on vend des opérations très lourde très
coûteuse pour tout le monde mais c'est à
ce prix là qu'on va arriver à se
protéger
l'autre danger des voyageurs qui
pourrait transporter de la terre
souillée sans le savoir le sport qui
rencontraient des traces de terre ces
chaussures étant ensuite du 10è pour
aller randonner dans nos veines
adresserait un vecteur vraiment probable
donc certains pays comme la république
dominicaine sont déjà mis à confisquer
des jeux sur salle de voyageurs en
provenance de pays affectés
des mesures drastiques pour se prémunir
de ce champignon sans danger pour
l'homme mais fatal pour le bananier déjà
dans les années 60 ils avaient éradiqué
la banane makanza aujourd'hui il
pourrait bien menacer la variété
cavendish
il faudrait alors des années pour créer
une nouvelle plante résistante à cette
souche du fusarium encore faut-il
qu'elles combinent de bonne qualité
gustative et qu'elles soient facilement
transportable désormais ce sont 400
planteurs de bananes qui retiennent leur
souffle en martinique